In some of the previous videos already
we talked about enzymes but in this video
I want to focus
of some of the "actors" who help the enzymes.
First, make a quick review.
Enzymes help the reactions to take place,
they lower their activating energy and help them
to run more often or faster.
We've already seen some examples of enzymes
and to clarify things,
sometimes in textbooks you can see the enzymes,
depicted here.
This is called an enzyme.
This is called an enzyme
and it is said,
that it interacts
with a substrate here.
It will affect the substrate.
This is a very abstract idea presented in a textbook -
to illustrate that the substrate and the enzyme fit like a key and a lock.
But they do not look like this
in the biological system.
We have to remember that when we talk about enzymes,
it's about proteins.
There are also RNA enzymes called ribozymes,
but most of the enzymes
are proteins.
We have long talked about proteins, their structure,
they are polypeptides,
different side chains of amino acids
determine the folding of proteins in different ways.
A better image of an enzyme would be something like this,
as this protein, which is folded in various ways,
maybe there are alpha-helices here,
maybe there are beta-folded sheets here.
It looks like this strange structure.
A substrate may be any kind of molecule,
which is attached to the protein.
You see some examples here.
This is actually a model of hexokinase
and you can see a little of the ATP
here's a little harder to see
the glucose to be phosphorylated.
The phosphorylation reaction will be helped by this great
protein structure, hexokinase.
In this video we will pay attention to that
when talking about enzyme and about
proteins, talk about amino acid chains,
but there are often other parts of the enzyme,
which are not proteins.
Even when we talked about hexokinases
and for phosphorylation of glucose,
we said that the enzyme lowers the activating energy
thanks to positive magnesium ions.
These positive magnesium ions
can hold the electrons of the phosphate groups
busy, pull them, so
the hydroxyl group may be linked thereto
with this phosphate without its electrons
obstruct.
In fact, these magnesium ions here,
are not officially considered part of the protein.
They are called cofactors.
We can have a cofactor here,
to be bound to the border protein.
Cofactor is needed
for the reaction, it plays a very important role.
Another drawing you can see in textbooks,
is something like this. It is said that
in order for the reaction to proceed
a substrate and cofactor is required.
Cofactor.
It sounds like a complex word,
but simply means the non-protein part of the enzyme.
The cofactor may be another molecule, ion or atom, which
helps the enzyme perform its function.
The cofactor is not part of an amino acid
either by a side chain or by a protein.
But it is another element that is needed
for catalysing the reaction.
We saw that we had hexokinase
magnesium ions that the complex receives.
So when people talk about vitamins
and minerals, many of the vitamins and minerals
function as cofactors in enzymes.
As you can see on this drawing
or according to what I have read, these magnesium ions,
green-colored cofactors.
These are cofactors.
Cofactor is the non-protein part of the enzyme.
Now we can make a subdivision of cofactors.
We can divide them into organic
and inorganic cofactors.
We saw inorganic cofactors,
these magnesium ions,
but there may also be sodium ions, calcium ions,
as well as many other types of ions that play cofactors.
They often "distract" the electrons and keep them busy,
for a reaction to occur.
There may also be organic cofactors.
There may also be organic molecules.
Remember Organic Molecules
contain carbon,
chains of carbon and other atoms.
A cofactors, which are organic molecules,
we call coenzymes.
Coenzymes.
There are many examples of coenzymes.
This is it
the enzyme lactate dehydrogenase.
He has coenzyme,
which you will often see when dealing with biology.
This is NAD.
Note that this is not just an ion but a whole molecule.
It contains carbon and we call it an organic molecule.
OAD is not a protein,
is not part of the amino acids that make up the proteins,
this makes him a cofactor.
And because it's a whole organic molecule,
we call it coenzyme.
Coenzyme
But like any other cofactor,
it allows the enzyme
to perform its function and to support the reaction.
You will meet quite often
coenzyme NAD.
It helps with the transport of hydrogen anions.
Hydrogen ions never exist alone, or at least very rarely,
they represent a hydrogen atom with an additional electron,
so they get a negative charge.
It helps to transfer this group
from or to a substrate,
as ND
can accept a hydrogen anion and become a NAD.
If you can see his structure,
is actually remarkable.
Maybe I will make a whole separate video for NAD,
because in so many textbooks I have seen only the letters
OAD and NAD, but I have always wondered what this compound actually is.
NAD is a remarkable molecule.
What he does is take
the hydrogen anion is here,
at this carbon atom, another bond may be formed
with hydrogen, I'll do this in another video.
I will show the mechanism.
This is a very cool molecule.
Remember, the theme of this video is coenzymes,
but we see similar trends in biology as a whole.
The name of NAD - nicotinamidadinedinucleotide
describes the molecule.
Nicotinamide - here below
is that part of the molecule,
this is the part that can take or give up a hydrogen ion.
We can say that this is the active part of the molecule.
Adenin, our good old friend adenine, who meets in DNA,
RNA and ATP. It is
our good old adenine friend here.
Finally we have a dinucleotide because
the molecule contains two nucleotides,
connected through their phosphate groups.
Let's think about it.
We have adenine here,
we have a ribose and a phosphate group.
If we only look at this part,
which I fenced,
we see the building unit,
of RNA,
if we have adenine here.
If we include all this,
if we include all this here,
we have ADP. The reason to call it a dinucleotide
is that it can be separated in another way.
We can say that we have one nucleotide,
which has nicotinamide here,
it is one of the nucleotides,
and the other nucleotide is here,
he has adenine.
That's why it's called the dinucleotide.
I hope this made NAD a less mysterious molecule.
We will see it often in the future,
but I like to look at its structure,
because it consists of all those components that
we'll see again and again, we'll see them at the ATF,
in RNA, over and over again.
But NAD is not the only cofactor or coenzyme.
There are many others, actually when someone tells you
to drink your vitamins or minerals,
is because they function as cofactors.
Vitamin C is a very important cofactor
for enzymes.
I will not go into detail
for all its different functions.
These are two different images of vitamin C.
Spatial model and model of spheres and sticks
right here.
Folic acid, again, two different models are shown.
Both folic acid and vitamin C are coenzymes,
if we have a protein here,
with its very complex structure,
we also have substrates, but to help -
I will make the substrates in another color.
We have substrates,
these are the molecules whose reaction is the enzyme
tries to catalyze.
But we may also have ions,
you may think about the ions
as for
cofactors, and we may also have organic cofactors
such as vitamin C for example.
Cofactors also support the mechanism
or to support the reaction.
Cofactors can help
charge stabilization can
to accept an electron or to give an electron,
can have a variety of features.
They can also be part of the response mechanism.